is outlining a must again every writer
is different I would say that if you
have any pretensions of working in TV
yes no script goes that no project goes
to script no episode unless they break
it and prep and that typically involves
either a beat sheet or an outline on the
future side of things if you're writing
on spec you know if you've got 12 months
and you want to just start with fade in
and see where it goes that's okay
but I definitely recommend outlining if
you've not outlined you should outline
at least once and see what that process
is like the way I approach it that I
think enlivens the experience is as I
said before we work with the characters
so week one batagor his character
treatment asks seven key questions of
the protagonist so you're engaging them
and really digging down into who they
are you know questions like what do they
fear the most that's an interesting
question
you know why does this story have to
happen to this character at this time
think about their sort of place in life
second week we do brainstorming is like
some of those exercises I was talking
about questionnaires biographies these
direct engagement exercises interviews
and monologues and streams of
consciousness third week we now move to
the plot so we talk about what's the
beginning of the story what's the end of
Act one what's the end of Act two and
what's the end of the story just give a
sense of those four primary plotline
points but we're also identifying
subplots my principal they are subplot
equals a relationship so whatever
characters you've come up with the
primary characters in your story then
start to look at them in terms of their
relationships and if you can work with
character archetypes that's very helpful
oh this is a protagonist attractive
relationship this is a protagonist
mentor relationship being Center and so
you start to think in terms of subplots
and week four we do we move to the
psychological domain and we talk about
these four theme line movements disunity
deconstruction reconstruction unity so
for the first four weeks it really is
focused on character and by the time you
get to the last stage where we're
busting up 3x5 inch index cards and
doing that whole thing you know that
you've spent so much time with the
characters and generated so much content
that it's there's a vibrancy to it
there's an aliveness there's a vitality
to it it's not just literally plugging
in this to that and this to that and
this to that you're really seeing the
story unfold and you're sensing that how
the characters are involved in the
protagonists psychological journey and
their art so I would say it's not
mandatory to do an outline I highly
recommend it you know if you feel that
it's better for you to write a treatment
version of it the more literary thing
that's fine too or a beat sheet but like
I do outlines and they can run to 25 30
pages long like single spaced because I
put everything in there like what's the
super conflict why are these characters
lines of dialogue effort how I'm gonna
get in and out of the scene transitions
to the next scene I put it all there so
I would say I would extremely encourage
people to do an outline yes and
particularly if they want to work in TV
they just absolutely have to so let's
say somebody doesn't want to do an
outline and you say alright that's fine
that's your style I even though I hope
mend it and then you read their script
and then you see that it could have
benefited from them taking time seeing a
story from what's your answer to that
well here's here's the thing I'd say
nine times out of ten I'm not going to
get that script because they're gonna
crash and burn by page 50 or 60 because
they don't know where they're going
anybody can write a first act it's very
you know you get a establish the key
characters the story universe central
conflict the the atmosphere and tone
something happens you know the inciting
incident or the call to adventure and
then something propels them off into
this new world right well so you can
probably off that energy go
okay the next 10 15 pages and then okay
maybe five more on but I don't know
where I'm going
maybe I better figure this out okay so
I'll write another 10 15 but well that's
stupid that doesn't really work
oh wow and so you know people will get I
think the number one reason why people
do not finish a script is because they
don't know where they're going if you do
an outline you do know where you're
going like well you're familiar happen
DC there's a Chesapeake Bay
bridge-tunnel I do a blog post on this
is pretty funny the Chesapeake Bay
bridge-tunnel extends from Virginia
Beach up to the Delmarva Peninsula which
is Delaware Maryland and Virginia right
and it's long it's like 20-some odd
miles long and so you've got this span
which is a bridge and then there's a
tunnel for like a mile and a half which
is creepy enough because you're like
under the Atlantic Ocean yeah and this
tunnel then you come up and there's a
mid part of the bridge and then there's
another tunnel there's another part of
the bridge that middle part of the
bridge which is about 10 miles out if
you go during the day you cannot see
land anywhere there's no land you're on
a bridge in the middle of the ocean if
you have an outline at least you know
where you're going and you just keep
going and going because that middle of
the story the act too can be so
discombobulating sometimes and so you
you know where you're going because
you've got the thing broken so you're
trusting that if you're going to come
out the other end so but yeah I have
rats absolutely I've read scripts were
like oh gosh eeeh they just didn't they
didn't nail the structure or the
structures a mass or but if there's
something there and the characters are
vibrant and yeah you can we can work
around that structure is is you know
it's it's important absolutely for
screenplays but there are ways to get to
that you know the the characters who are
alive and vibrant
you know compelling that's really the
harder part of thing in some respects
great sorry you just figured a memory of
I remember being a kid and being afraid
to have my grandparents drive me over
that oh maybe that's why I'm afraid of
bridges yeah there was a subconscious
coming out so yeah so you brought it out
yeah
I forgot all about that
you